- All right, everybody,
let's wrap things up
with something really sweet
I found on social media.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
(audience cheering)
Okay, so check out this painting.
It's by an amazing new artist.
The thing is, he doesn't use brushes.
He doesn't use a roller or pallet knives.
What he does is totally unconventional.
Let's get him on the line
right now to explain.
Everyone say hi to Mack
and let's bring in his human companions,
his partner Corporal Kevin
Henderson and the founder
of Friends of the Canine
Vests Midwest, Emily.
Oh my gosh, so y'all gotta
explain like how did this start?
Like did he always love painting
and then it became a fundraising thing?
Explain how this all started.
- So, I created Friends of
the Canine Vests Midwest
back in 2020 for my
love of law enforcement
and dogs in general.
I've been in rescue for over 25 years now.
And I just found out that these,
a lot of dogs are working
without vests and they need vests
and they need food and they
need medical attention,
they need retirement packages,
they need get well baskets,
they need all kinds of things
with these four-legged
heroes that we have.
And I was like, we need to come up
with a really cool way to fundraise.
And so, we came up with this concept
where the dogs get to be the Picassos
and we even had one of our
paintings go for $2,000.
So, it's a fun and great way
for us to raise money
to do what we need to do
for these canines.
- Oh my God.
It is hard not to just
keep your eyes on Mack.
He is adorable.
So, Mack has made a few paintings, right?
- Yeah, so I've worked
with Emily for years
and he's made several
just trying to raise money
to get these vests for all these dogs.
We've been able to get vests
for all three of our
agency dogs through Emily.
Main thing is just trying
to keep the dogs safe
as possible when they're out working.
They're put in very dangerous situations
and they're very good dogs
and they deserve everything they can get.
- Absolutely.
Oh my God, that tongue
hanging outta his mouth.
I mean, I just love him so much.
Thank you so much, Emily,
Corporal Kevin, and Mack.
I'm liking your post right now.
This is such a cool thing to
do and a cool way to fundraise.
That's not all though, everybody.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of G2 the go-to pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to support dogs putting themselves
at risk on the front lines.
So, they're gonna be writing a check
to Friends of the Canine
Vest Midwest for $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
- [Emily] Awesome.
- Aw, thank you guys so
much for your service.
Thank you to all our guests this hour:
Billy Ray Cyrus, Firerose,
Sam Jay, Christie Kohut,
Arian Langsome, and Marcy Bursack.
You know what?
Have a great day, everybody,
and if it's not, try and change it.
(rock music)